[Music]
[Applause]
uh do we have Mad Dog Russo when he was
on first take and uh before we bring
Chris in he was railing on Taylor Swift
and Travis Kelsey and the coverage
and who takes their girlfriend two
minutes into a relationship to visit
mommy and daddy nobody got stats I mean
I didn't even got a strong walk it out
and now all of a sudden she's a big kid
the City chief man she's never heard a
lot
wait
time out maybe all right
well Mad Dog Russo host a Mad Dog
Unleashed on Sirius XM and host of high
heat on MLB Network let's start out
first of all good morning Chris uh let's
start out with Taylor Swift and Travis
Kelsey can you at least Embrace this
that it's content
uh uh listen uh you know it's fun more
than anything else it's a little
fabricated to me all of a sudden uh
meeting Mom and Dad a meeting Mom at 10
minutes into the relationship and I was
a little shaky it's also good TV Dan as
you know better than anybody else let's
get them going let's get Stephen A let's
get let's get Molly involved uh we are
in the entertainment business as we know
I gotta sit up there and scream they're
not gonna get you know they're not gonna
break down Cubs and Suzuki dropping a
Fly ball I can't say Atlanta I'm not
gonna have Stephen A go crazy on the
Cubs collapsing so everybody can
identify with that that's part of it too
you know you gotta remember when you're
doing that particular segment you got
people behind you and you want them to
react as well because the facial
laughter and all that and they're gonna
have more of a reaction with Swift and
Trace and Kelsey than they are on
something else plus the fact that do
feel it stupid they must have spent
three hours on it and the game was lousy
but Burkhart and my buddy Olsen went on
and on I couldn't take it banging
against the window so you put everything
together I gotta kill two minutes what
the hell let's have some fun that was
the idea but when you look at topics
that we address now we seem to you know
take the treetop here it's it's kind of
the same teams same topics at least we
try to shoehorn them into every show
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to take something in a little
different angle and try to get a little
mileage out of it you know and what
could you can get a lot of mileage out
of Kelsey and Swift they're two huge
stars and if I take a different angle
with it it will get attention and no in
this case I actually do have a different
angle would I make a big deal about it
no but I did say it Monday on the radio
you know I did bring it up Monday on the
radio this is before TV God I can't take
Swift in the owner's box or in Kelsey's
box and I did a big deal about that on
Monday too which got a little bit little
attention but nobody's got to tell you
when you say it there especially in my
goofy way to do it it's going to get a
lot of attention but you know uh I hope
when anybody got too ticked off on it I
did the gummies the week before so I
there's a there's a goofy element now
with this what I'm mad about and that's
why I thought it'd fit into the mode it
fit into what we're trying to do in that
little segment there now I'll be fair I
had a lot of people wanting me on last
couple days including Fox Business News
and I wouldn't do it because I don't
want to go too crazy and make this you
know and and and and extend this too
much I did it on Wednesday we got some
mileage out of it now let's move on and
go on maybe I'll do it again Monday when
I see it
I don't have to do it on Thursday and
Friday after I did it on Wednesday
that's Overkill if you know what I mean
yeah my problem was that you have
Patrick Mahomes his ankles injured he
gets taken out of the game nobody asks
any questions about his ankle they ask
him three questions about Taylor Swift
and that's when I go come on guys let's
focus on what is real here and that's a
guy who's had an injury and maybe that
comes back uh you know and and hurts
them in the long run we're talking good
point now he got over the ankle last
year in this in the postseason so maybe
people think that he'd do it again but
that's an excellent point uh with the
ankle I didn't even think of that uh but
you know I also think the game was so
bad yeah that game was you can't watch
the Bears you just can't there's a
couple teams in the NFL you can't watch
bears and jets you can't watch them
because of the quarterback play and I
think the fact the game was so bad adds
okay what we're gonna do here we're
going to kill some time here's Taylor
Swift banging on the window
excited
but she must love Travis Kelsey if she's
willing to watch Zach Wilson play
football Sunday night
at MetLife Zach Wilson and you know I
asked another thing that annoy me this
week and I love Joe Willie we all do can
Joe take does Joe got a pile on then
jeez I mean is he gonna kill him too The
Whole World's killing him and then Joe
goes on and kills him as well I thought
that was a little overboard didn't you
think so yeah I was disappointed in Joe
because that position is about
confidence he's clearly lacking
confidence he it's not all on Zach
Wilson but everybody is piling on him as
if he's the reason why I'm just amazed
you take away Rogers and the Jets are
this bad I mean is it really predicated
on one guy ah it's an excellent point I
thought they'd hang in there and be a
pretty decent Team without Rogers I
think part of it's the schedule you know
Dallas that's a tough game and then the
Belichick you know the Patriots Owen two
need the game in a worse way uh you know
that game could have gone either way uh
you know but they're gonna lose again
this week so I mean and New York
football Dan you know the Giants lose
this week their next two games of
Buffalo and Miami on the road I think
it'll be one in five if they lose to
Seattle which they certainly could and
the Jets are going to lose this week
here it is we thought that
that the New York football was going to
be great and it's funny two weeks ago
Goodell came into ESPN
you know downtown yeah and I saw I
didn't do the spot but I saw him there
and we were talking about the Jets and
he made a big deal to me about how the
Jets were going to be a good team and
now that I thought about it it's Roger
trying to make sure that the Jets were
not going to be flexed out out of all
these games because you're going to flex
the Jetson Prime Time constantly you're
gonna have to flex these games the heck
out of there nobody's going to want to
watch the Jets if they're one and six
with even with the good defense now what
would you have asked Adele you didn't
get a chance to do the interview what is
there one question that you want an
answer to yeah the one thing I would
have asked Roger Roger how do you
answer the idea that you suspend every
NFL player for playing some sort of
gambling thing yet you make a fortune
with gambling
that's hypocritical so it's okay for
author blank to make a fortune with
FanDuel and all the gambling ads and if
Calvin Ridley plays fifteen hundred
dollars he gets suspended for a year
yeah how is that right either you think
gambling's bad or you don't so you can
make a fortune yet the players if they
play get killed that that's what I would
have got I probably would have gone
there myself talking to Chris Mad Dog
Russo Mad Dog Unleashed on Sirius XM
also host of high heat on MLB Network
give me the storyline that's left to be
played out in the regular season in
Baseball American
uh Seattle Texas
and uh the um and the uh and the uh
Astros one of those teams is not going
to make the playoffs Toronto is going to
get in Texas is playing Seattle Seattle
had a great win last night they had a
two out two on double in the bottom of
the ninth by the shortstop Crawford to
win the game against Chapman so that
kept them alive so they Trail by a game
Houston and they showed Texas by a
couple now remember it's tight you know
this but the fans may not it's Tyler
Baker it's not an extra game and
Seattle's got the tie breaker on Houston
so if they finished tied Seattle makes
it and not the world Champs and
Houston's in Arizona this weekend and
the Diamondbacks haven't clinched the
spot yet so I think that three for two I
think that is your storyline in the
American League West the other storyline
would be the Cubs who were playing great
with 33 and 14 that in trade Bellinger
and now they can't get a win and now
Miami he controls Destiny for that last
playoff spot in the NL East and think
about this for a second Dan no Mets no
Yankees no Red Sox no Giants
and maybe no cups baseball is going to
go in the postseason with a maybe no
Houston baseball is going to go into the
postseason with uh not a lot of their
Staples you know they're you know their
their big ratings Getters see how that
works here beginning next week the best
sports franchise best team in New York
right now is well that's a good question
it's not the Jets it's not the Giants
I hesitate I I mix arrangers
I mean the Rangers are pretty good
lavalette's a good coach the Rangers two
years ago got to the semi-finals last
year they had a bad loss but and they
fired the coach maybe I'll say the
Rangers uh you know but the Knicks are
in the conversation right yeah next year
in the conversation they're a second
round playoff team but the Giants are
bad they're not going anywhere the Jets
we just discussed uh the Mets stink and
the Yankees stink so that doesn't leave
you a lot of teams they say you lose
those big four uh yeah it's um the
football in New York is going to be bad
again well it is already but it's going
to be bad again it really is good to
talk to you
good to talk to you man have a great
weekend thank you
Mad Dog Russo always fired up